habla francés o no o vale vale
básicamente el escenario es un lugar de
skate y nosotros somos los skaters vamos
a tener que hacer algunos trucos creo
que el diseñador se inspiró mucho en los
looks de los skaters de los 90 lo puedes
ver por el pañuelo los pantalones cortos
las chaquetas de Jean que en realidad no
son muy cómodas para patinar pero me
siento muy bien con ella
[Música]
el gran regreso de los 90
definitivamente la marca japonesa kidil
para su colección otoño-invierno 2023
2024 presentada en París hiruki suya su
defiende La pureza y el caos la libertad
es preocupada y la sensación real de
poder perderla en cualquier momento Como
por ejemplo cuando te caes del monopatín
no es probable que esto le ocurra al
maestro supremo japonés joji yamamoto
que este año cumplirá 80 años y para
quien pensara en el mundo es casi más
importante que hacer ropa que es
preciosa Todo hay que decirlo esta
colección se llama No hagas eso pero qué
es eso no consuman demasiado
están matando el planeta
estamos matando el planeta
yo también soy culpable
solo de vivir
cómo representó esta idea en su
colección
quería relacionar el título de la
colección con medio oriente
medio oriente es un lugar heterogéneo es
una muy buena mezcla hay tantos estilos
diferentes tanta gente tantas cosas
revueltas
que los rostros los cuerpos se vuelven
hermosos
al igual que las obras de arte casi
todas las colecciones tienen ahora un
nombre Walter van bairen Duck que
también dirige el departamento de moda
de la Real Academia de Bellas Artes de
amberes Bélgica y que al igual que joji
yamamoto observa como el desastre se
apodera del mundo ha llamado a los suyos
necesitamos ojos nuevos para ver el
futuro se trata de una conexión
compuesta principalmente por
protecciones empecé a trabajar en
exoesqueletos
al mismo tiempo en el propio esqueleto y
las protecciones que lo rodean
crear una especie de Aura para sentirse
protegido
hoy necesitamos ese tipo de protección
para vivir en el mundo en el que vivimos
quiero aportar energía positiva
forma parte integral de mis colecciones
Para mí es importante motivar a la gente
sorprenderla que aprecie la belleza
es un juego sobre la belleza todo el
tiempo
[Música]
me encanta hacerlo me gusta superar mis
propios límites para dar a conocer mis
ideas en todo momento
[Música]
el californiano parisino Rick howens se
siente amargado Por crear colecciones en
tiempos de guerra para aliviar su carga
se dirigió a la grandeza de la antigua
Luxor en Egipto el resultado variadores
hombros Ultra anchos chaquetas de
aviador de poliamida reciclada
certificada todo ello con referencias al
bondage y la colección
hermosa muy bonita
los hombres llevan preciosos abrigos
clutch que lucen Fabulosos los
pantalones son preciosos rasgados en las
nalgas Rick Owens les ha dado forma y es
muy accesible eso es lo que hago con mi
marca
creo que es una colección increíble muy
bien pensada
y no es un circo no Esto no es un circo
en absoluto hoy no hay animales de circo
está muy bien cortado es muy fluido muy
portátil y luego ese toque de feminidad
absolutamente necesario en el armario
masculino
siempre Necesitamos siempre
remontémonos a los años 90 Cuando un
grupo de activistas tomó las calles de
París para protestar contra el maltrato
a los inmigrantes a la comunidad
lgbtqia+ a cualquiera que fuera golpeado
por movimientos extremistas este grupo
se llamaba red warriors los guerreros
rojos y así se llama hoy la colección de
gianni friott
el rojo el rojo es violencia es pasión
es sentido y prohibición Ahí es donde
uno quiere ir
es unisex sin género sí sin género por
fin los chicos podrán llevar falda los
chicos por fin llevarán faltas
bordadas faldas peludas en realidad se
trata de tener un vestuario basado en
una personalidad en un deseo es un poco
como un encuentro amoroso así que sin
hablar un chico y una chica pero
pensando realmente en otra cosa
una colección que también toma prestado
los códigos de la difunta Vivian
westwood
de hecho es un homenaje antes de su
muerte
pero al hecho de que mis modelos a
seguir en la moda en fin como mujer hay
muy pocos sobre todo vivían westwood y
también Sonia rica así que la idea era
ella estaba muy comprometida
políticamente como yo puedo estarlo con
mis colecciones Así que para tomar un
poco de los códigos de Vivian sobre el
tartán y ver cómo puede encajar con
nuestras nuevas generaciones dándole un
giro y por desgracia ella falleció Pero
eso lo hace aún más no sé un bonito
homenaje ahora vamos a juntar los
nombres de estas colecciones los
guerreros rojos tienen que ponerse
nuevos ojos para mirar al futuro y
salvar a los niños Terribles de Luxor No
hagan eso vayan a vestirse